this is a super interesting story on
Monday I played for you a clip of
FoxNews propagandist Tucker Carlson's
program where he was against the
assassination by Donald Trump of the
Iranian Kurds leader Kasim soleimani and
I said during that segment tucker
carlson is the against against the
assassination which is good but he's
against it for the wrong reasons for
example tucker carlson said we have
domestic issues to focus on not we
shouldn't be assassinating iranian
leaders in iraq now i agree with that
the problem is the the domestic issues
he wants to focus on are the wrong ones
like for example the fact that he
believes immigrants make the country
dirtier including brown immigrants from
Latin America I agree with Tucker the
assassination was bad I don't agree with
Tucker on the domestic issues he wants
to focus on now I also said on Monday
even if Tucker is against the
assassination for the wrong reasons if
he pierces the echo-chamber
of some Fox News viewers it's still a
good thing to have him on Fox News
saying he's against what Donald Trump
did in Iran
it appears that Tucker may have pierced
the echo chamber of Donald Trump himself
there's a new report in BuzzFeed news
that Donald Trump has been watching the
Fox News coverage about what he's been
doing in Iran and that he appears to
have been influenced by a Tucker Carlson
straight up saying he's against this
Sean Hannity sort of still sucking up to
Trump but I believe saying that he
wouldn't be in favor of boots on the
ground in Iran so this is one of those
Curb Your Enthusiasm moments where the
camera slowly zooms in on Larry David
doing the on the one hand on the other
hand thing on the one hand it's terrible
that Fox News actually influences
presidential policy we note from watches
Tucker Hannity talks to Hannity directly
watches Fox and Friends it's a peanut
gallery influencing presidential policy
and that's terrible on the other hand if
Trump watching Fox made him less
interested in war with Iran then we kind
of have to be happy with that at least
to some degree here's a reminder of what
Tucker Carlson said on late last week
early this week which we talked about on
Monday threats in the region if you
don't live in Washington
the translation that would be in hostile
Middle Eastern countries places where
American troops would never be in the
first place we're not for the insistent
demands of non geniuses like Max Buddha
and John Bolton but nevermind no one in
Washington is in mood for big-picture
questions right now questions the
obvious ones like is Iran really the
greatest threat we face and who's
actually benefitting from this and why
are we continuing to ignore the decline
of our own country in favor of jumping
into another quagmire from which there
is no obvious exit by the way if we're
still in Afghanistan 19 years sad years
later what makes us think there's a
quick way out of Iran and so on nobody
is thinking like that right now instead
chest beaters like senator Ben Sasse of
Nebraska are making the usual warlike
noises the ones they always make this is
very simple Ben Sasse wrote in a
statement last night general Soleimani
is dead because he was an evil bastard
who murdered Americans which is
essentially true Soleimani was certainly
a bad guy but does that make killing him
quote very simple it does not nothing
about life and certainly nothing about
killing is ever very simple in any
politician tells you otherwise is dumb
or is lying
yes Soleimani was linked to the deaths
of Americans nobody mourns his passing
but Mexico and China are also linked to
the deaths of Americans each has flooded
our country with narcotics from which
tens of thousands of Americans die every
single year not that anyone in power
cares so does that mean we get to bomb
Oaxaca
can we start assassinating generals in
the People's Liberation Army now there's
another interpretation here that
suggests Trump may be getting foreign
policy advice from Fox is better than
the alternative and this might sound
absolutely crazy is it possible that the
advice Trump would get from Fox News is
less radical than what he would get from
the people in his administration so I'll
give you a very specific tangible
example Tucker Carlson is horrible but
he has an anti interventionist streak
he doesn't seem bloodthirsty to go to
war with whoever he can maybe we're
better off with Trump listening more to
Tucker and less to for example Stephen
Miller who is an absolutely unhinged
radical I'm thinking out loud here and
this may be totally misguided in a
perfect world
in an even remotely reasonable world
FoxNews would not be influencing
presidential policy but as a sort of
Sophie's Choice situation if you ask me
do I want Stephen Miller guiding Donald
Trump's foreign policy or do I want
Tucker Carlson guiding Trump's foreign
policy
maybe tucker carlson is the preference
as horrible as he is this is not a
normal conversation this is not
something we would normally think about
in a normal administration we might be
saying which school of economic thought
would we prefer the president's domestic
policy be based on under Trump were
saying would we rather Trump get foreign
policy ideas from xenophobe propagandist
Tucker Carlson a radical white
nationalist Stephen Miller still between
two bad choices there can be a less bad
one the 2016 election is certainly
evidence of that the country made the
wrong choice there and maybe I preferred
from getting foreign policy advice from
anti interventionist Tucker Carlson than
from that absolute whacked-out adviser
Stephen Miller let me know what you
think